last week the GTX 1080 was offered for
$450 on two instances with these types
of prices for the 10 series as it even
makes sense to wait for the 1100 series
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so if you guys
didn't notice already GPU prices have
been dramatically falling at least in
the US for about AMD and NVIDIA and JP
your prices are hitting all-time lows
for example $450 for the GTX 1080 is the
lowest that we have ever seen
also other cars aren't doing bad either
right now you can get a gtx 1066
gigabyte card for 270 dollars a gtx 1070
for 400 others and you can even get a
gtx to native di for less than MSRP for
$650 to determine if you should wait for
the 1100 series the performance of the
1100 series is very important so how
well will the 1100 series perform well
here's the truth
the 1100 series is not going to be a
game-changer it is most likely not going
to have great racing technology or
tenser course and if it does it will be
reserved for the top level cards so it
really won't affect the average consumer
however at the same time it is not going
to be just a rebrand of attempt series
because it will most likely have GTD or
six memory and beyond the Tommy areaa
architecture and we should be seeing a
solid boost over Pascal at about 20%
start come out to about one increment
level so for example the GTX 1160 should
be around the performance of the gtx
1070 and the gtx 1170 should be on the
performance of the gtx 1080 and so on
and so forth so pretty much of all
levels of GPUs except for the flagship
the GPU booth should be pretty
significant and the reason that the GPU
boost isn't that significant on the
flagship products is because the gtx
1180 TI isn't going to be coming out yet
once that comes out that will be a lot
better than the gtx 980ti so overall the
performance of the 11 her series will be
a good boost of the 10 series but it
won't be anything too major so how much
is the 11 her series going to cost well
right now the
so many rumors and there really are just
small speculation and this one rumor is
even suggesting that the GTX 1160 is
going to cost $500 now I'm not sure who
came up with this but that makes no
sense whatsoever
the GTX 1160 will at best be as good as
the GTX 980 which you probably won't be
but even in such a scenario the GTX 1080
is less than $500 right now so why would
anybody buy a GTX 1160 when they can
just go out and buy GTX 280 for a
cheaper price and get more performance
on top of that if they went the GTX 1080
route they can get third-party variants
of the GTX 280 instead of just a
Founders edition of the GTX 1160 so in
my opinion $500 for the GTX 1160 is
completely false
Nvidia isn't stupid they know that the
GTX 1160 is a mid-level card and they're
not gonna prices so high now there may
be a little price increase over the last
generation of cards for example the GTX
1166 gigabyte card may cost 330 dollars
instead of $300 with the 1066 gigabyte
card and 1180 may cost $750 instead of
700 like the GTX 280 but really that's
the only difference we were going to be
seeing up to $50 and I really doubt that
a bigger difference and that will occur
because once again it really just
doesn't make sense and all of you guys
who are suggesting that Nvidia is going
to launch the 1100 series for an
expensive price so that it so makes
sense for people to buy the 10 series
well I don't think that is true because
it tends to reason dropping so much in
price so why would that happen if the
GTX the LEM hunter series is going to be
more expensive in that case the 10
series could have just maintained MSRP
and the 11 or series could have came in
for a more expensive price but since the
10 series it dropped me so much in price
right now I really doubt that it's going
to happen
and finally what exactly is the 1100
series coming out well again we really
don't have any solid evidence of
anything right now however it has been
over two years since the 10 series came
out and I know that a lot of you guys
are like well that's not that long at a
time but this is one of the longest
running series for in video also you may
be saying that Nvidia
not going to release the 1100 series
right now because there is no
competition from AMD to do so but even
if there is no competition even though
there is no competition from AMD right
now India can't just keep pushing
forward without releasing an 11 horror
series especially with how much hype
there is around it on top of this
releasing the 1100 series will only
boost sales more for Nvidia so why would
they avoid doing that Plus Nvidia and
Adam core partner sales during the
second quarter of this year well
actually a lot lower than usual so it
makes sense for Nvidia to come out with
the new series right now to boost their
sales and what better way is there to
boost sales other than launching a new
series right before the holiday season
of 2018 also GT dr6 memory production
has already been going on for quite a
while now and I don't think that's just
a coincidence so keeping all this in
mind all the main cards of the 11 horror
series which are the 1180 1170 and 1160
should come out within the next three
months
so overall the 1100 series will be a
solid upgrade over the GTX 10 series
it's not going to be a game changer but
it will be a good upgrade also it may be
a little bit more expensive than the 10
series launched before but it's not
going to be super expensive like some
rumor suggests so should you buy a 10
Series card right now or wait for the
gtx 1100 series well in my honest
opinion this really comes down to
personal preference do you want the
newest tech available and want to be
up-to-date or do you want the best value
available if you want the best value
then the 10th series is definitely the
way to go whether you buy it right now
for a really great discount or you wait
for the 11 emissaries to come out for
the 10 series crisis to drop even more
and then buy it then either way the 10th
series is definitely not going to be
beaten by the 11 hunters in terms of
value so if you're looking for a value
go with the 10 series however if you
want the newest tech with all the little
new features and a slight performance
edge over the 10 series and you're okay
with paying a little bit more for the
1100 series then the LEM horror series
is for you in the end both of these
series will perform really well and last
for a very long
time and as a result it really just
comes down to personal preference and
what you value more do you care more
about price for performance or having
the newest technology available but
that's pretty much all I have for you
guys right now so are you guys going to
be waiting for the 1100 series or are
you going to be buying a 10 series GPU
right now or one that 11 or series comes
out make sure to comment down below what
you guys think because I do read all my
comments I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like to do that make
sure to drop a like and consider
subscribe me if you would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time this is Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]